Okay
Was mit meinem Start
Was mit meinem Startmenü. Leute mein Startmenü ist kaputt
Mein Startmenü ist broken
Wie kriege ich das wieder gefixt? Alter, mein Startmenü ist kaputt. Kack wait. Ich mach schon mal die VM an
Vielleicht fixt sich das gleich von allein
Hoffe ich mal
Mein fucking Startmenü ist kaputt, man
Chat, hattet ihr schon mal ein kaputtes Startmenü? Mach ich mal ein bisschen was entspannteres machen
Okay, Leute, mein Startmenü ist kaputt. Ich kann nix mehr starten und nix mehr rein tippen
Ja, unter Linux ist es kein Problem. Unter Linux geht das einfach. Guck
Unter Linux würde es einfach funktionieren
Aber wie kriege ich das jetzt wieder gefixt? Go Wizard, danke schön für den Sub. Ein bisschen Go machen. Alter, was ist mit meinem Startmenü los?
Ein bisschen Go machen wir heute auch. Okay, Task Manager
Kann man Explorer irgendwie abschießen oder so?
Okay, Explorer ist weg
Ja, YOLO inject
Klingt als hätte ich irgendein Virus, ist es aber nicht. Das ist so ein Maus-Highlighter
Hey, es geht wieder, nice. Ja
Super. Gut, dass es im Hintergrund läuft, aber
Guck hier, YOLO, YOLO inject
Das gehört zu YOLO-Maus
Damit kann man, damit kann man seinen Mauszeiger
Beispielsweise in allen MMOs, wo das heute viel zu klein ist, alles in der Mauszeiger zu klein groß machen und rot färben und sowas
Ganz praktisch
Okay, mein Startmenü funzt wieder. Das ist schon mal nice
Jetzt ist es auch blazingly fast. Okay, jetzt ist es auch blazingly fast
So wie das heute sein muss
Okay, wir machen mal Package-Updates in der FFM, dann zeige ich euch, was wir heute machen. Also wir machen dort weiter
Was will der denn, wo wir das letzte Mal aufgehört haben? Was möchte der denn jetzt? FFM-Pack? Ja, okay, gib ihm. Jawohl, halbes Internet runterladen
Ach, Qt 6 ist raus. Ich habe meine Zeit lang wirklich sehr interessiert und fand das sehr spannend
Die neuen Qt-Versionen verfolgt, aber ich habe schon ewig nicht mehr reingeguckt
Die hatten tatsächlich jede Version irgendwas cooles drin, auf was man sich freuen konnte
Ich frage mich aber, wie groß die Verbreitung da in der aktuellen Zeit noch ist
Ich meine, von allen Cross-Plattform-Frameworks auf dem Desktop wird das wahrscheinlich eines der weitest verbreitetsten sein
Jetzt bei Elektron und so außen vor
Aber wie weit die Verbreitung insgesamt ist, weiß ich nicht, weil es ist halt hauptsächlich C++
Man kann zwar ein bisschen Python machen, aber letztendlich kommt es bei Qt um C++ früher oder später nicht rum und C++ ist halt einfach der Suck
Schon irgendwas Spannendes beim Black Friday gefunden? Nö, ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht groß geguckt
Ich habe, ich habe mal nach SSDs geguckt, weil SSDs kann man nie, nie genug haben, ja
Ach, guck mal
Inhalationsgerät, bam
Wie es, wie es mir einfach, wie es mir einfach Kopiumgerät vorschlägt hier
Ja, ja, die Kinder sind voll glücklich, wenn ihnen die Mama das aufsetzt
Kopium-Time
Ansonsten, es gibt halt nur Schrott, das gucken wir, vielleicht, vielleicht gucke ich mir nachher mal eine Runde an
Wenn ich, wenn ich keinen Bock mehr auf Rust habe, weil mich Rust zu sehr aufregt
Ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig
Was für ein Smartphone verwendest du eigentlich? Ein iPhone
Also um genau zu sein, zwei iPhones
Ein iPhone
14? Ist 15 das aktuelle?
Dann ist, ist, also wenn 15 das ganz aktuelle Top, also der erst letztens Release ist, dann habe ich ein iPhone 14 Pro
Aber nicht Pro Max, weil mir das zu groß ist
Das mit 120 Hertz Display
Und dann habe ich von der Firma, habe ich noch, ich glaube ein iPhone 12
Aber benutzen tue ich eigentlich fast ausschließlich, wenn ich was mache, außer ich muss halt für die Firma irgendwas gucken
Das iPhone 14
Wir haben hier eh erstaunlich viel Apple Zeug
Wir haben drei iPads, dreieinhalb iPhones im Einsatz, ein paar Zwei-Personen, lul weh
Aber Android-Geräte habe ich auch noch ein paar
Ich sage halt immer, es ist sinnvoll, das zu verwenden, wo das jeweilige System seine Stärken hat
Ganz ehrlich, wenn das iPhone 11 gut funktioniert und nicht schnell genug ist, warum?
Feature-mäßig tut sich doch die letzten Jahre über eh nicht viel
Guck mal, ich meine
Wenn das meiste, worüber du ausflippen kannst, irgendein komischer neuer Side-Button ist, das sagt doch schon mal alles daraus, wie sinnvoll das Upgrade ist
Ich meine, ich hätte den auch gerne, den neuen Action-Button
Aber es ist wirklich nicht wert, da irgendwie tausend plus Euro auszugeben
Nur 70% Batterie
Ja gut, wenn die Batterie nachlässt
Aber man muss ja auch mal gucken, wie das funktioniert
Insofern, ob du es jetzt bei 20% oder 30% neu auflädst, man macht ja auch keinen großen Unterschied
So, hat das jetzt geupdatet?
Reboot
Macbook, nö, was soll ich mit Macbook
Lul, da drehe ich durch, wenn ich ein Macbook
Also Apple auf dem Desktop hätte ich wirklich gar keinen Bock
Apple auf dem Desktop hätte ich wirklich gar keinen Bock
Was kommt als nächstes?
Was kommt als nächstens?
Was kommen als am nächsten Tag?
Was kann ich边suchen, wen ich es verpasse?
Ich mache mir BAS es zu was ich es verpasse,
Weil ich kein Scheiß bin ich verdaderscheine ich zu worstfallen
Jeder sah nur das Gefühl
Jeder schaute nur den Fehler
Einacht nur gefolgt
Es gab nur eine löschbar Kampagne
äh äh äh go build build mode chat library
minus o
achso äh
ja
meinetwegen heißt das so
let's moven wir oh shit
alter was äh
eigentlich bin ich kein Mathämier
ähm go build
hier Benchmark so wie heißt das
WebRTC wie hab ich das genannt
wie soll wie soll das heißen
WebRTC
linux.so ok
wir müssen kurz setup machen dass das funktioniert
ok
so
die go geschichte kompiliert
ey warum heißt das go lib
das soll nicht so heißen man
achso hä
warum funsten das nicht leute
ist halt beim output gleich so man
soll mir recht sein außerdem kann ich den output
direkt erstellen lassen doch in
backend
WebRTC linux.so
genau so
da muss ich doch gar nichts moven
so das sind wir
so jetzt kann ich
starten jetzt kann ich euch zeigen was passiert
also
copy always
.net
wir sind hier
run
gut alles klar so chrome aufmachen
und wenn
wir jetzt auf local host
local host port 8080
gehen werdet ihr was sehr unspektakuläres
sehen und zwar
connection und network connected
also was passiert ist folgendes
kann man mal vielleicht die browser
tools irgendwie ein bisschen
wo ist der button dafür
irgendwie so
dass wir es nicht total übertrieben
also der baut
eine WebRTC Verbindung auf vom browser
zum backend und das funktioniert
folgendermaßen also WebRTC ist
eine
Blazingly Fast Connection ja
der WebRTC ist eigentlich
für Echtzeit Audio Video
Kommunikation gedacht kann auch für Chat Nachrichten
und so benutzt werden
aber hauptsächlich muss man sagen ist WebRTC
im Audio Video Segment
Sektor
zu Hause
und das heißt wenn ihr Teams
verwendet oder Zoom verwendet oder
sowas was wahrscheinlich
jeder von uns ist eigentlich Slack
noch angesagt wobei Slack ist eher
Chat weniger Videokram
und
das ist alles WebRTC unter der Haube
so
und
das funktioniert jetzt
ich glaube mittlerweile
schon
aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt Slack seit Ewigkeit
nicht mehr gesehen also Teams hat
ziemlich zugeschlagen und eigentlich benutzt
Slack war mal eine Zeit lang
richtig groß ja
aber irgendwie ist mittlerweile echt Teams
einfach nur
eigentlich das verbreitetste schlechthin
es kommt ab und zu mal vor gerade
wenn man mit irgendwelchen Amis
konferieren muss dass sie irgendwie
Zoom Calls einladen oder so
ok so also ich zeige euch
jetzt mal was ich gebaut habe was wir
umstellen auf Go es ist
umstellen auf Rust es ist relativ
übersichtlich also
Ausgangspunkt des ganzen ist ein
.NET Backend
ihr seht das ist sehr überschaubar
das ist alles aus mehr besteht das nicht
das macht hier ein bisschen
das callt hier ein paar Sachen in Go
das gucken wir uns gleich an
dann gibt es einen AP Endpunkt
mit http get
slash WebRTC Start
dort
erzeugt er eine neue WebRTC Connection
und schickt an den Client also an den Browser
zurück die
Magic WebRTC
Verbindungsaufbau Dinger das sieht dann so aus
zum Beispiel ist vollkommen egal
dafür fände ich eine Library muss ich mich nicht mit auseinandersetzen
schickt er zurück an den Browser
der Browser nimmt das ganze
der Browser
versucht auch eine WebRTC Verbindung aufzubauen
callt diesen Endpunkt
und dann
nimmt er das was er von dem
Backend geschickt kriegt
setzt das als Remote Description
das ist so eine WebRTC
Verbindungsaufbau Geschichte
warum das so heißt man weiß es nicht
aber WebRTC Handshake
funktioniert so
eine der beiden Seiten also bei WebRTC
das ist wie gesagt für Echtzeit
Peer-to-Peer Video Übertragung eigentlich gedacht
bei WebRTC sind beide Seiten
gleichzeitig Server und Client
und es können beide Seiten
die Verbindung initiieren das funktioniert so
eine Seite
erstellt so ein
Offer Package
wie heißt das
so eine
Offer Anfrage
schickt das an die andere Seite
und die erstellt darauf eine Antwort
und schickt das zurück
und wenn beide sich drauf einigen können
dann wird die Verbindung
aufgebaut
drauf einigen heißt
die tauschen
ihr seht das hier vielleicht auch
die tauschen zum Beispiel aus
die tauschen hier zum Beispiel
Endpoints aus für Video
man sieht hier mein Docker Interface
wird auch mitgeschickt was ziemlich ppiger ist
ja das ist UDP
das ist UDP tatsächlich
komplett UDP
man kann auch TCP verwenden
aber das ist für Videosachen ja meistens
nicht so wichtig
die tauschen sich beispielsweise die Endpunkte aus
für das Video also ihre IPs
und sie tauschen sich aus
welche Codecs sie unterstützen in dem Fall
unterstützt mein Server
meine Serverseite nur
H264 mit diesem Profil
sonst nichts
im Endeffekt einigen sich die zwei Seiten
darauf was sie denn jetzt
als Videos austauschen wollen
also in der Offer steht drin
hey hallo ich bin Client
oder beziehungsweise Server XY
das sind meine Endpoints
das sind meine Video Audio Codecs die ich unterstütze
und
dann antwortet
die andere Seite
drauf und sagt ey
alles klar
ich unterstütze auch
dieses Video Format
lass uns mal anfangen
Video auszutauschen
und dann wird die Verbindung aufgebaut
also das ist im Prinzip das wofür ich die WebRTC Library verwende
kann man da
einen Key hinterlegen? Ja kann man irgendwo
aber ich lasse das aktuell alles die Library
handeln
es geht auch mit
TCP
du kannst wenn du
also
normalerweise muss man sagen geht das
geht das
verhältnismäßig gut ich hab das auch schon mal gemacht
indem ich beispielsweise meine Tür Gegensprechanlage
auf mein Handy gestreamt hab
da drüber
per WebRTC
da hab ich den ZipCall gemacht
nur mit dem ZipCall dann die Sachen gepusht
aber
das ging tatsächlich erstaunlich gut von außen
wenn es gar nicht geht
kann man noch so einen
ich hab vergessen wie der Kram heißt
Turn, Stun
wie auch immer Server einbauen
wo das dann quasi einmal über eine externe
IP läuft der Verbindungsaufbau
um schön
Löcher ins jeweilige
NAT zu machen
aber es geht erstaunlich gut ehrlich gesagt
ja und
intern im Netzwerk ohne NAT dazwischen
ist es eh kein Problem
so wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben
also das ist so die Basics wie so ein WebRTC
Aufbau funktioniert
und eigentlich ist jetzt
nachdem die Verbindung steht
ich kann übrigens auch zeigen dass die Verbindung steht
Moment
Moment wir sind in
Ha guck mal
Chrome ist schlau genug
About WebRTC
Das hier suche ich genau
Guck und jetzt kann man
sich hier den Verbindungsaufbau ansehen also man sieht
sie sind lokal
Connected
Connection ist aufgebaut
und
der Transport rundherum ist auch aufgebaut
so und
also das ist die komplette
.NET Seite mehr passiert nicht
der
also der
die Serverseite generiert so ein Offer
Package das kommt dann
hier rein also der Client sagt
Add TCP Connection
dann callt er diesen Endpunkt
dann kriegt er diesen
Kodex
das muss er sich dann setzen
als
Remote Description nachdem beide Seiten
Server und Client gleichzeitig sein können muss man immer
einstellen was er selbst ist
und was die andere Seite ist
dann setze ich
quasi das dann erzeugt der
Browser eine Antwort darauf in der Antwort
steht dann drauf ok ich unterstütze
mindestens einen Kodex den du auch unterstützt
wir können Videos miteinander austauschen
und dann schickt er das ganze zurück
und das geht dann hier an den Post
Endpunkt von der .NET Anwendung
und dann ruft er hier jeweils
Go Low Level Web RTC
Sachen auf ja also hier am Anfang
ruft er einmal
in Go die Sachen auf
dass er UDP Netzwerkgeschichten
set up
dann dass es ein Video Track gibt
in dem man was reinschreiben kann
hier lässt er sich die
Connection Sachen generieren
und hier setzt er dann die Sachen
die Antwort vom Browser
für die
Connection
ich glaube wenn wir das jetzt gleich in Rust
bauen das ist relativ klar
es ist auf jeden Fall recht übersichtlich
ich zeige euch jetzt schnell die Go Seite
ja und am Ende
jetzt könnten die eigentlich Videos austauschen
warum ich das hier so ein bisschen buntig gemacht habe
einfach weil es schöner aussieht
also der guckt hier
sobald sich der Connection State
ändert schreibt er das halt hier rein
wichtig ist dass beides Connected ist
sowohl hier quasi der
Transport und die eigentliche Web RTC
Connection an sich ich könnte jetzt da drüber
beispielsweise Audio austauschen
Video austauschen mehr oder weniger fast in
Echtzeit oder auch einen
Data Channel aufmachen wo man den mal zum Beispiel
für Chat oder sowas verwenden kann
so also das Frontend ist übersichtlich
67 Zeichen
da müssen wir heute nichts dran machen
und an dem C-Sharp Backend müssen wir auch so gut
wie nichts machen weil das stellen
wir ja um von Go auf Rust
ich zeige euch jetzt was Go
macht und das ist das was wir heute in Rust
versuchen nachzubauen
und zwar
es ist auch recht übersichtlich wobei es
noch der komplexeste Part ist an der
Stelle
das sind die ganzen Funktionen die vom .NET
Backend aufgerufen werden
das erste was der macht ist
Init Network sieht man auch hier
Init Network passiert folgendes
der erstellt
so eine Liste
mit supporteten Codecs
also in dem Fall supporten wir nur
steht hier oben
in dem Fall supporten wir nur
H.264 das ist das was ihr auch eben gesehen
habt in dieser langen Text
in diesem langen Text Output
doch das habe ich selbst geschrieben
mit Error Handling
allerdings
nicht überall Error Handling
an vielen Stellen schreibe ich
wird der Error auch einfach weggeschmissen
ne wird nicht rausgeschmissen
es wird Go rausgeschmissen
zu Rust
oder mal gucken ob es in Rust funktioniert
ne das habt ihr eben auch in der
gesehen in diesem
Verbindungsaufbau wir unterstützen
nur H.264
und das ist halt so die Codec
Parameter
für unser Video was wir unterstützen
so also als erstes
leg deine Liste an mit
supporteten Codecs
warum brauchst du noch das .NET Projekt
das .NET Projekt brauche ich
weil das eine noch ein bisschen umfangreichere
Webanwendung wird
und ich keinen Bock habe
das in Go zu machen
auf der anderen Seite
so mega umfangreich
wird die Webanwendung gar nicht
also
vielleicht
ist das nächste was wir machen
.NET noch rauszuschmeißen
mal ganz davon abgesehen Go fliegt ja auch
raus das wird ja heute in Rust neu
gebaut vielleicht
alles in Rust aber das glaube ich
nicht dass ich mir das antue so abartig
wie
ja das ist wirklich also
Interop mit anderen Sachen ist
Go echt ppga das habe ich auch
schon gemerkt was es am Ende
bringt ja das kann ich auch noch mal kurz
erzählen also
du kannst damit zum Beispiel
jede x beliebige Webcam
oder ja also alles
alles was FFmpeg einlesen
kann und was ein
H264 Stream hat
bekommst du damit eben als Video im
Browser also sprich du hast irgendeine billige
China Chinesen Webcam
die kannst du dir damit im Browser anzeigen lassen
du wirst jetzt sagen hey
normalerweise
kann man auch Webcams im Browser
anzeigen lassen kann man
und kann man auch gleichzeitig
nicht es kommt immer drauf an was
was die Webcam unterstützt
und was die Webcam anbietet
die aller aller wenigsten Webcams
bieten WebRTC
also quasi mehr oder weniger Realtime
Streaming an und dann hast du auch
nur eine Webcam drauf also
sprich ich will eine Webseite haben
wo einfach meine ganzen Webcams drauf sind
ich glaube aktuell sieben Stück hier im
Haus also ich hab
warte mal lass mal bedenken ich habe
drei Stück draußen
eine
in dem Raum wo die Katze immer abchillt
und
eine im Flur und eine im Keller
sechs Stück, sechs Stück sind das
sechs Stück
und
da will ich eine Webseite haben wo die alle drauf angezeigt
werden mehr oder weniger
achso und das ganze lasse ich in Home Assistant letztendlich
anzeigen entweder als iFrame oder als
Popup oder so aber das hat ja mit Home Assistant nichts
zu tun
Seite und ich will das halt möglichst Echtzeit
haben und auch
Connection Abbrüche handeln also das
Backend wird eine Webanwendung in .NET
das macht
nicht viel mehr als die
als die Webseite ausliefern
und das ganze FFmpeg Zeug
wir brauchen ja auch noch FFmpeg zum Auslesen
von den Videostreams
das ist relativ simpel das haben wir im Stream auch schon gemacht
also wenn man weiß wie FFmpeg funktioniert
also
das C Interface von FFmpeg
geht das erstaunlich gut
wie gesagt vielleicht
gefällt mir das in Rust dann auch so gut dass ich auch
.NET noch rausschmeiße und es einfach komplett in Rust
mache wobei ich
dann würde ich es lieber komplett in Go machen
weil wenn ich es komplett in Go
mache ist letztendlich
ja auch kein Interop
mehr nötig mit anderen Sprachen und
dementsprechend
aber ich habe schon mal FFmpeg in Go gemacht
das ist auch Pains Champ weil du da
zäh Sachen callen musst wie dem auch sei
es geht ja auch darum dass man ein bisschen was
was lernt nicht so sehr das was super
auch nie da gewesen
ist rauskommt so
und
ich wollte euch nochmal kurz zeigen
ja ganz ehrlich die .NET Templates
kannst du vergessen du brauchst eigentlich
nur zwei Templates in .NET du brauchst
Console und Web
Rest reicht
das ist aber schwierig mit CMD
einzelne
Frames aus einem
RTSP
H264 Stream abzugreifen
und die dann weiter zu
leiten über WebRTC
da wüsste ich jetzt net
wie ich das rein mit CLI
und Streamen irgendwie über Standard
in oder so machen soll
so
also
die Go als erstes macht der InitNetwork
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal das was wir neu bauen müssen
in Rust
InitNetwork ist relativ simpel
der erstellt einfach eine Liste mit Codecs
aktuell wir supporten plus H264
und mit in dem Fall kriegt es halt die
ID 96
so da gibt es ein bisschen Error Handling der nicht wirklich viel macht
ihr könnt euch
auch paniken weil
ich will nicht return können wir nicht gleich sagen
Panik
Keckel
eigentlich wurscht weil wir wollen Go gar nicht weiterverwenden
so dann
Settings Engine
wir wollen UDP verwenden anstatt
TCP ich hab beides mal angelegt
aber wir verwenden UDP
sieht man auch hier
der legt eine neue Settings Engine an
sagt Network Typ UDP
und dann als Port
verwenden wir 36363
das heißt
alle WebRTC Verbindungen werden
multiplexed über diesen Port
normalerweise ist es bei WebRTC und Videogramm
so dass für jede neue Verbindung
und jedes neue Video ein eigener
Port aufgemacht wird
das ist ok
das einzige wo das mega
nervig ist
wenn du Firewall freischalten musst
und mir ist es lieber ich muss nur
ein Port freischalten als alle
also
der
listen auf UDP
mit TCP geht es auch auf ein Port
hier 35353
ich kann ja auch gleich zeigen dass es funktioniert
so dann
erstellt er so eine komische WebRTC
das muss man machen weil die Library das will
dann als nächstes
wird ein Video Track created
in den ich noch nichts reinschreibe aber ich brauche
ein Video Track das die Verbindung ordentlich funktioniert
Create Track
er generiert eine
Unique Track ID
erzeugt einen neuen Track und
pusht den Track in
ein Array, äh eine Liste
für später
dann als nächstes
callt er Create Connection
Create Connection ist das hier
Create Connection
wird eine neue WebRTC Verbindung erzeugt
nicht verzeugt
erzeugt
der Track der vorhin angelegt wurde wird der WebRTC
Verbindung hinzugefügt als neuer Video Track
dann
passiert das was ich euch schon erzählt habe
es wird ein Offer erstellt
dieses Ding hier
also ein Offer erstellt
dann wird eingesammelt was er für
Endpunkte hat also im Prinzip sind das die
IP Adressen
dann wird Connection ID
generiert, Connection in die Liste
gepusht und hier
zurückgegeben an den C-Sharp Teil
die Client ID und den
Text und das kommt dann
letztendlich im Browser raus
und wenn der Browser antwortet wird das
hier gecallt und das ist auch das letzte was es gibt
dann wird das hier gecallt
er holt sich die Connection raus dazu
passt den String raus
also wieder den C-String umwandelt es in den Go-String
was hat der hier für Schmerzen
use CamelCase instead, ja nervt nicht
so und dann setzt er das
die Antwort vom Browser in die
WebRTC Verbindung und dann ist der
Handshake fertig und die Verbindung
aufgebaut, so das ist
im Prinzip alles
hat man das halbwegs verstanden
also im Prinzip besteht das aktuell aus
ähm
155 Zeilen Go
37 Zeilen
C-Sharp und ein bisschen HTML
also wir sind
so ungefähr bei 300 Zeilen
also ich denke es ist relativ übersichtlich
achja, eine Sache die ich noch nicht
gezeigt hab, damit
damit man Go
Sachen aufrufen kann auf C-Sharp
muss man ein bisschen Interop Magic machen
und das passiert hier
Rust kommt jetzt
und das passiert hier, also man
muss dem quasi sagen wie die Funktionen
heißen die man in Go definiert hat
und welche
welche Return Werte
und Parameter Argumente die haben
dass er die aufrufen kann
aber ansonsten, an Logik passiert hier eigentlich
nichts drin, das ist alles
mag vielleicht jetzt erstmal
verwirrend sein, aber wir bauen das jetzt in Rust nach
und ich hoffe das funktioniert
blazingly fast natürlich
was sonst
und abfuck kompliziert
wahrscheinlich auch
ok, also dann
dann verschieben wir
das mal das Go Ding auf
Desktop 8, das ich ja nachher nachgucken kann
und erstellen jetzt
das Rust Projekt
Rust
New Project
nennen wir es mal
WebRTC Rust
weil ich glaube
ich hab den anderen Krempel ja auch
WebRTC
Go genannt, dann nenne ich es
WebRTC Rust
Create
so, jetzt müssen wir
ein paar Sachen setzen, also das Ziel ist
wie gesagt, eine Library
erzeugen in Rust mit
Interfaces die wir dann aus .NET aufrufen können
das funktioniert auf exakt
die gleiche Art und Weise wie
das mit Go funktioniert
hier in dem Fall
erzeugt Go eine Library wo es eben
diese Funktionen drin gibt, die dann aufgerufen werden können
und Rust wird genau das gleiche machen
also sprich
Rust erzeugt eine Library
wo es dann so eine Funktion zum Beispiel drin gibt
so
das mit das funktioniert
da müssen wir jetzt erstmal abgucken
wir haben das alte doch gebackupt
weil da haben wir doch schon ein bisschen
Rust mäßig gebastelt
welches ZSH Theme benutzt du?
das ist
selbst gebaut, allerdings basiert
das auf einem
also als Prompt ist das
Starship ES
und
dort gibt es
Configuration
wo haben sie denn hier Beispiele für?
Theme?
Ja
keine Ahnung, die haben ja normalerweise
Beispiele für Themes
aber ich bin gerade zu pega
das zu finden
zumindest, ah Presets
hier unten, Themes heißt Presets
und das hat nicht so viele Presets
dabei in Starship
und ich habe
das hier genommen als Basis
Pastel
Powerline basiert auf
M365 Princess
also da haben sie sich alle
gegenseitig befruchtet
inspirationstechnisch
nur dass ich das noch ein bisschen
angepasst habe, also ich habe die Schrift
beispielsweise, die Farbe ein bisschen
kontrastreicher gemacht und
ich habe beispielsweise
einen zweizeiligen Prompt draus gemacht
hier ist es ein einzeiliger Prompt
ich mag einzeilige Prompte nicht
ich mag eher zweizeilige Prompts
was man auch hier dran sieht
das hier einzeilig wäre richtig noch ekliger
da wirst du gar nichts sehen, zweizeilig geht das hier halbwegs
und meine .files
hast du tatsächlich, hatte ja gerade schon jemand im Chat
.config
Starship
da ist meine Config drin
ja
und da kannst du dir das abgucken, also ich habe noch ein paar zusätzliche
Sachen gemacht, ich habe zum Beispiel
bei .net Projekten noch reingeschrieben
was es für
Projektframework ist
versus was systemweit
installiert ist
und so Zeug
was das hier vorne ist, habe ich keine Ahnung
warum das da überhaupt
angezeigt wird
achso
weil ein Header-File drin ist oder was
zeigt ja noch die
installierte GCC oder
oder
was auch immer das ist
für eine Version an
naja gut, alles klar
so wir müssen jetzt noch ein bisschen was rüberkopieren
damit das funktioniert in Rust
und zwar, wir haben ja letztens schon mal ein bisschen
gebastelt was
Interop zwischen .net und Rust
angeht, wir müssen im Prinzip
das da
das da brauchen wir
Cargo-Tommel
Dependencies
Lib
Name WebRTC Rust
vollkommen ok
Source muss nicht main.rs sein
sondern
wo ist der Rename-Knopf
man, das ist so
Lib.rs muss das ganze sein
und
ich glaube, das war es
schon
gehen wir mal in den Ordner rein
der Musik war immer so laut
Cack wait
so, gehen wir mal in den Ordner rein
Repos, WebRTC
Rust, Cargo, Build
ok
alter, das halbe Internet
wird wieder runtergeladen und kompiliert erstmal
so, da müssen wir uns nämlich noch
was rauskopieren hier aus dem
alten
Projekt, wo wir gebastelt haben
Lib.rs
im Prinzip
können wir
eigentlich, weil wir haben ja schon damit mehr oder weniger
angefangen
das hier mal rüberkopieren
wie, ich hab kein Vim
wait a minute, ich hab kein
ich hab kein Vim
mit
mit Clipboard
was ist das
warum hab ich kein Vim mit Clipboard-Funktion installiert
Moment, was
hab ich nicht
ich hab den normalen Vim, der hat glaube ich gar keinen
egal, wir wollen uns jetzt nicht mit
Vim-Gedöns aufhalten, ok
ist das Way oder E3
so
gut
geh mal weg, geh mal weg hier oben, Rust
alter, Rust
geh weg
ok, Main
so, also, jetzt müssen wir gucken
wie wir den krempeln
was hat er denn eigentlich für Schmerzen
das müsst ihr doch nach wie vor erkennen hier
Bild, bildet doch auch
aber meine
Idee ist der Meinung, es bildet nicht
null
na geil
mal neu starten
wie lädt man hier, kann man hier irgendwie ein Projekt reloaden
ist ja noch Beta
was ich programmiere, ein WebRTC
also ein
Web
Backend für WebRTC
mit einer WebRTC
Rust Library
ach, jetzt hat er es gecheckt
ja, das ist die Rust-Idee
von JetBrains, ob die was taugt
keine Ahnung
also ganz ehrlich, ich bin
ja nicht der große Rust-Checker
was ich bisher an IDE-Support gesehen habe
für Rust ist alles ein bisschen PaintChamp
und das auch
aber das ist noch mit am wenigsten
nervig, ok
also, jetzt müssen wir diesen Krempel
erstmal übersetzen von Go
nach Rust
da fangen wir jetzt mal an
also das erste was wir haben ist diese
Network-Funktion
ich kopiere mir mal kurz das
Go hier rüber und dann vergleichen wir
das mal mit dem was wir hier gebaut haben
in Rust, ob das so halbwegs
passt, also
wir legen eine MediaEngine an
das mache ich hier auch
so
dann registern wir einen Codec
PayloadType
ok, 96
PayloadType 96
Typ Video
ja, ne, ne, ne
das mache ich nicht mit Chat-GPT
selbst
also ich würde sagen
soweit haben wir das
schon mal drinnen, dann eine
Settings-Engine
dann eine Settings-Engine
wobei, sag mal so
ich habe es hier umgedreht, aber
das macht jetzt ja
nicht wirklich einen großen Unterschied
dann eine Settings-Engine
mit Settings für UDP
habe ich auch
zur UDP-Port 35353
wobei ich hatte 36363
glaube ich
UDP-Port
ok, so
und als letztes
gibt es noch das hier, was übrig ist
von Go
und das habe ich hier glaube ich auch schon
das letzte Mal gebaut in Rust
aber viel mehr
hatten wir da glaube ich nicht mal gemacht
also RP
also in Go sieht das so aus
RP gleich WebRTC New RP
with Settings-Engine
with Media-Engine M
das habe ich hier auch
with Settings-Engine
with Media-Engine
und das hier ist
um es als globale Variable zu haben
genau
das ist Rust-Magic dafür
um es als globale Variable zu haben
ui
und dann würde ich sagen
der Teil
der Teil passt schon mal in Rust
der sieht genau so aus wie in Go
nicht viel Unterschied dazwischen
so dann machen wir mal weiter mit
also
das klappen wir mal ein
das haben wir
ja
Memory-Leaks sind erstmal nicht so wild
Create Track brauchen wir jetzt
da bin ich nicht sicher
das haben wir noch nicht gemacht
also
Create Track
in Go sieht das ganze so aus
erzeugt sich eine
Random-Track-ID
und dann
legt er einen Track an
und speichert den sich
in
eine Liste
da geht es jetzt los
das wüsste ich schon mal nicht
wie ich das in Rust gescheit mache
bei der Sache hier flippen die ganzen Rust-Liebhaber
schon aus, aber wenn du Interop mit
anderen Sprachen machst, wüsste ich nicht wie man es gescheit machen soll
zum Stage-Sharen
wir bräuchten jetzt sowas wie
eine
Track-Liste
entweder Tracks
und das ist
tja
Collection-Typen
in Rust
ich brauche eine Hash-Map, sowas in der Richtung
so ein Dictionary quasi
Hash-Map
gibt es, nice
zwar eine Hash-Map aus Track-ID
also quasi ein
sagen wir mal ein Int
zum Beispiel
ein Int
und einer
einem Track, also einem
wie heißt denn das?
heißt das auch Local Static
Sample
ja, nice, top
ist das dann
ein Server pro Client 1 zu 1? Nee
da können belieb- also
beliebig, bis der RAM ausgeht
viele Clients hinkonnekten
und die kriegen alle dann die gleichen Video-Streams
geschickt
nee, nee, da können so viele
und alle über den gleichen Port, das ist ja das Coole
das wird alles Multiplex über den gleichen Port
deswegen musst du nur eine Sache in der Firewall freischalten
stimmt
da war irgendwas
ich weiß aber nicht mehr was
ich glaube ich musste
ich musste
in Rust noch was aufrufen für free
naja
wie gesagt, scheiß auf Memory-Leaks, Hauptsache es funktioniert
erstmal
so, Cargo-Build, Moment
es funktioniert noch, da kann irgendwas nicht stimmen
da stimmt irgendwas nicht, Leute
da stimmt
ich
wenn in Rust einfach was kompiliert, dann stimmt was nicht
ok
also, dann legen wir mal los
wir tun mal
wir hardcoden erstmal, ok
also, wir brauchen eine Track-ID
wir sind in Rust, also
Track-ID 2
so, hardcoded Track-ID, ok
das hier lassen wir weg
so, und das heißt
wir brauchen jetzt einen Track
und jetzt ist die Frage
wie lege ich das in Rust an
Track-Local-Static-Sample
irgendwie so
ah, New, guck mal da
der braucht
ein Codec
eine ID und eine
Stream-ID
oh Camel, no, never
but I've tried
Erlang
and
also
for languages with
many parentheses
Erlang
and
can't remember, I think it was
Closure
or something
on Java
oh Camel, ist gleich Rust
mit GC, ok
debated
also, ich weiß, dass der ursprüngliche
Rust-Compiler
in oh Camel war
so, wir funsten das hier jetzt
Track-Local-Static-Sample
also, wir brauchen
eine RTC
RTP-Codec-Capability
ich glaub, das ist das gleiche
was wir hier, ne
ok, Rust, es geht schon los
also, was brauchen wir jetzt?
ok
und jetzt, Klammer auf
MIME-Type
Channels
Yep-Clock-Rate
was will der von mir?
ah, Default
PyFed
ey, können wir nicht?
hier ist es doch, hier steht es doch
Moment, warte mal, hier ist es doch
hier ist doch alles
warte mal
kann ich nicht?
sowas geht in
Rust wahrscheinlich nicht, ne
das
das dachte ich mir fast schon
Static
ne, geht nicht, weil
Missing-The-Type-For-Static
wieso steht doch da?
muss ich irgendwie noch sowas machen?
ey, hab ich das gefunden?
das kompiliert doch im Leben nicht
alter
das war
hätte mich auch ganz stark
gewundert, wenn das jetzt einfach kompiliert
wobei, der meckert gar nicht da drüber
der meckert hier drüber
sec
ähm, ne
was?
ok, das geht
in Static aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht
warum auch immer
keine Ahnung, weil
PyFed Rust, wir machen
jetzt einfach eine Funktion draus
public
ok, keine Ahnung, get
äh
oh
jaja, ist gut, ich hab schon was
getrunken
sowas hier
sonst das jetzt
kann man das hier nicht
returnen einfach, Moment
warte mal, rust
fn muss da noch
davor, pubfn, ja
und jetzt will er return type
mach mal deinen
Cargo-Check unten an
ah
was will das von mir?
anscheinend ist es aus
aber das große preisfrage ist, wie mach ich es an
ok, gut, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt
shit reinschreibe
ok, werden wir gleich sehen
also, get capabilities
schreibt man das so?
das schreibt man doch im Leben nicht so, oder?
hörste?
capabilities
ok, das, das, kompilier das jetzt
ja, nice
so, das heißt, wir können jetzt an der Stelle
das einfach wegschmeißen
track local static sample
gut
so, da kriegt man jetzt
kode capability
das da
kann man da reinhauen
jetzt
track id
keine Ahnung, 1, 1
wir wollen jetzt
draufgeschissen erstmal
to owned
nur mal gucken, ob das auch ordentlich läuft
so
das funst
ja, gut, gut, gut
also das brauchen wir nicht
wir haben den track
panik, kommt weg
das wird ja viel kürzer sogar als in rust
so, und jetzt muss ich den track
hier drinnen irgendwie speichern
welchen package manager
benutzt du? für was?
so, jetzt haben wir hier
irgendwie ein
hashmap
für tracks
linux
ja, pacman
achso, das da meinst du
das hier
ok, wie kriegt man jetzt in die hashmap was gescheites rein
moment
den haben wir noch gar nicht initialisiert
das wird er mir hier auch sagen
nee, das hier unten
müssen wir, wir müssen das glaube ich nochmal
initialisieren
set, hashmap
new, hoffe das funst
jetzt
ok, noch, noch, kompiliert
alles, was ich bastle
ein
frontend, wo ich per web
rtc videos hinstreamen kann
mischung aus go.net
für die webanwendung und ein bisschen
html, hauptsächlich ein bisschen
um rust zu lernen
also, ich hab das
schon in go gebaut
um zu testen, ob es funktioniert
es funktioniert und jetzt bauen wir das in
rust nach
genau, der twitchkiller
was macht
eigentlich dings hier, kick
letztens
mal wieder reingeguckt, übelst
zwielichtiges zeug wieder gesehen und
gleich wieder ausgemacht
das ist echt nicht die twitch
konkurrenz, keine ahnung
das deckt glaube ich
ein ganz anderes
klientel ab als twitch
ok und jetzt müssen wir
den track inserten in die hashmap
also, tracks
insert
ne moment, das ist in einem
ganz lock
das heißt, ich brauche jetzt
right?
ne
was brauche ich denn jetzt
get, get mut
ok, get mut, alles klar
rust, rust things
unwrap
zack
natürlich geht es
es wäre viel zu einfach, wenn das
irgendwie, das muss ja mut vorne hinten wahrscheinlich
noch, ne
es wäre viel zu
einfach, wenn das in rust
einfach gleich funktionieren würde
das, ok, jetzt geht es
wieder los, man
was hat er jetzt für schmerzen, man
also, wie habe ich das denn mit api
gemacht bisher, habe ich das überhaupt schon mal irgendwo
gemacht, ah, get
get muss man machen, moment
get mut, was will er denn von mir
cannot borrow immutable
local variable tracks as mutable
cannot borrow immutable static
what, was willst du
what
rust
ne, das kann es nicht sein hier, oder
das geht nämlich mit static dann
ne, das geht nicht
oh gott, rust, alter
ok, get funktioniert, ne
ne, doch, get wird schon mal funktionieren
ok
tracks insert
aber das geht jetzt nicht, weil es
nicht mut ist
oh je, oh je
jetzt kommen wieder rust-Geschichten an
start, ja, er sagt
nicht track id, track
ok, hier sagt er mir
geht nicht, weil not mutable ist
und jetzt bin ich schon wieder
mit meinem latein am Ende, was rust
angeht, what
let track
was, mut
was, was will er von mir
genau, doppelpunkt
ja, aber das geht doch nicht
aber, aber get mut
funktioniert nicht, shit, man
aber
get, get mut
funktioniert nicht, weil
ich cannot, cannot
borrow immutable
oh man
ok, wahrscheinlich
ist ein one slot nicht genug, ich brauche
wahrscheinlich noch ein mut
mutex oder irgendwas
rust
jetzt kommt
oh, zu schnell, rust
please
ok, once, once lock
mutable
ok, hier, da
also, rust
once
what you want is a mutex or rw lock
ja, moment, rw lock
rw lock
alleine reicht mir doch gar nicht
oder
rw lock
rw lock alleine reicht mir glaube ich nicht
ne, moment, ah, fuck it
shit
fertig
ich, ich, ich bin verwirrt
warte mal, rw lock geht
doch gar nicht
weil ich, weil ich hier jetzt nicht
sagen kann, oder
weil ich jetzt hier nicht sagen kann, hashmap
new drinne, oder doch
oder doch
ich bin mir da unschlüssig
ok
ok, rw lock
rw lock
und jetzt
muss ich sagen, right, ne, right
unwrap
oh man, alter
was
alter rust
ok, mutable, ok
präge, prä
oh
cannot call
non const, ok, das dachte ich
mir doch
das heisst, ok, ok
leute, ok, ich, ich, achtung
outplayed rust, outplayed
ich weiß was rust von mir will
die wollen ein once lock
gerapptes
rw lock, wollen wir wetten
das wollen die haben
die wollen ein once lock
rw lock
kannst du mal abholen
was du da machst
ich baue was
ich in go gebaut habe, um
in rust, und aktuell versuche ich
rust dazu zu bringen
dass ich in eine liste was reinschreiben kann
und das ist in rust schon mal gar nicht so einfach
so, rw lock
new
achso, und jetzt hashmap
hashmap, new
jetzt präge, präge, präge
präge
ok, tracks, ok
also rw lock, jetzt brauchen wir
get, dann brauchen wir
unwrap
right
ok, guck mal
es gibt keine fehler mehr, es gibt keine fehler mehr
easy, es kompiliert
also, ok
wir brauchen ein rw lock gerappt in once lock
obviously
ich mein, wem das nicht klar gewesen ist
der, dem ist auch nicht mehr zu helfen
wir brauchen eine hashmap
also eine generic hashmap
gerappt in rw lock, gerappt in once lock
rw lock, gerappt in once lock
klar ist klar
alright, easy würde ich sagen
ist das, das ist nicht einfach
nur easy, das ist
ultra
easy, weil
warum ich mir das antue, weil alle
coolen leute rust verwenden, und ich will auch
cool sein
intuitiv, ich hätte die sprache auch so
designed, ja
was ich gerade verstanden habe
also ich habe eine mischung verstanden
ich habe das keckel und keck weight
gepaart mit weird champing
ja, wobei ich glaube, die richtig
coolen rust leute
die schreiben das sogar so, gell
also
tchatke, es hat funktioniert
wir haben einen track
erstellt, also wir haben das
go zeug nachgebaut, wir haben einen
track erstellt
mit der id
achso, ja moment
wie macht man
gibts ein to string, ah nice
eventuell gibt es auch eine
einfachere lösung, wenn ihr eine
kennt leute, keine ahnung
also
static rw lock rust
also das problem ist ja
dass in diesem globalen kontext
hier, nur
statische sachen erlaubt sind und keine
initialisierung von
zum beispiel eine hashmap
also insofern bleibt ja nur
once lock, weil ich das so eine art
constructor mäßig initialisieren muss
und dann noch ein rw lock da drinnen
weil ich die mutable reference nicht aus dem once lock
rauskriege, was auch immer
ok
wieso ich die id benutze
weil ich es ausprobieren will
und weil das chat brains zeug in der regel
ziemlich nice ist
ok, weiter, insert track
wie geht das go zeug
also in go
haben wir als nächstes jetzt
create
connection, leute
das bauen wir jetzt in
das bauen wir
jetzt nach in rust
also
create connection, als erstes
brauchen wir die api funktion
und legen eine neue per connection
an, das habe ich auch schon
gemacht in rust, das gibt es
hier, dann adden wir die tracks
ok, das klingt auch logisch
also hier haben wir unsere
unsere api objekt
wo wir neue connections anlegen können
die offer, die wir hier erzeugen
das kommt erst später und das hier
kommt auch erst später
so, hier haben wir die per connection
jetzt brauchen wir eine loop
über alle tracks
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
for i in
tracks, das geht so im Leben
nicht, tracks, moment
ich brauche jetzt get
unwrap
äh read
jetzt tatsächlich nur read
unwrap, ne
unwrap
einfach so
let tracks, da machen wir hier lokale
variable draus, ja
tracks
und das jetzt
und jetzt
iteraten, ok
nice, nice, nice
kann die ide irgendwie
use destructing
declaration, ok
also einmal für id
und einmal für
per connection
ich merke schon, die rust Leute
schreiben das nicht gerne aus
so, kompiliert es noch, ok, nice, nice
also
das habe ich bei rust gelernt, sobald es
kompiliert ist, dann geht das auch
meistens
kann man das hier irgendwie umbrechen
dass man das irgendwie ein bisschen besser lesen kann
ich weiß
nicht ob das die korrekte
formatierung ist für rust
aber es ist
fällt mir einfacher zu lesen als
das 500 mal unwrap hintereinander
for loop ist verboten
wie sowas ist
hä, also
verboten offensichtlich ja nicht, aber was
ist der Vorteil
zum loopen
von einer
collection keine loop
zu nehmen
das klingt doch schon beim aussprechen
weird, oder
das ist so verständlich, ja, das stimmt
das ist
ein gutes rust kriterium
so, jetzt muss ich
die per connection, die braucht jetzt
add track
sowas gibt es hier bestimmt auch
natürlich nicht
Moment, ich bin ja auch
massiv pp gar
das ist ja auch nicht per connection
was mache ich denn für ein blödsinn
das hier sind ja die tracks
nicht die per connections, das sind die tracks
und die per connection
die habe ich
hier, so add track
track
so
geht nicht
weil, warum
unused
await, perfekt
unwrap
noch besser, exzellent
und jetzt
mag er nicht, weil
what
expected
arg dünn track local
plus send plus sync
but found track
local static sample
was expected der
ein
arg dünn track
local send sync
das ist ja fast schon schlimmer
als c++ die syntax hier
ok, ich kopiere mir das einfach mal raus und frage
ihn, ob es das überhaupt gibt
ne, das gibt es gar nicht
ok, arg kenne ich, das ist
reference counting zeug
machen wir jetzt einfach
arg new
und ok
dann packen, ok, check
chatgill, five hat time, ich weiß
wie es geht, arg new
track
track local
ne, einfach nur track
ok, das geht nicht, weil
ach
der will das Objekt direkt haben
und nicht einfach
dereferenzieren geht nicht
vermutlich, weil
er sagt, cannot move
oh, oh, Leute
ich weiß, was wir machen müssen
obviously
habt ihr das auch wieder alle nicht erkannt
dabei ist es total offensichtlich
also ich als rust
kenner, wusste das schon, ich wollte euch
einfach nur
testen, ob ihr das auch
wusstet, was ist denn move
und und, was soll ich
machen
move und und
äh
und und
äh, das ist für irgendwelche callbacks
also, chatgill
ich weiß, ich weiß, was wir machen müssen
und zwar
obviously
wie jeder weiß
ist das hier oben
noch nicht lang genug
das heißt
wir brauchen jetzt kein
once log lw log hash map
wir brauchen ein once log lw
log hash map
arg
das war eindeutig zu kurz noch
wir brauchen noch
ein weiteres unwrap irgendwo
wieso über die hash map
weil die, weil die random
ids, oder random
theoretisch random ids bekommt
jede, jeder track
so
und jetzt
muss ich natürlich beim track
hinzufügen schon sagen
new
track
ah ja
jetzt seht ihr
und jetzt machen wir
das ganze nochmal, arg
und jetzt kann ich das
hinzufügen, weil jetzt ist es ja schon in
einem arg drinne
nein, kann ich nicht
warum nicht
expected arg dünn, found arg
ah
ok, das ist ein reference counter
da hab ich was drüber gelesen
das ist ein reference counter
ich muss jetzt quasi sowas sagen wie clone
gell
pifat time
die sache ist bloß die
clone ich jetzt den track oder clone ich jetzt
den arg
ich will den arg clonen und nicht den track
ok, track hat gar kein clone
nee, to own will ich wahrscheinlich
to own will ich nicht, weil es ja
in der collection weiter bleiben soll
ich clone
den arg
dann passt das doch, oder
was convert to ufkz
äh
was ist ufkz
universal function call syntax
ufkz
ok chat
was ist, was ist, was ist geileres
was ist geileres rust
punkt clone
oder arg clone track
was, was machen die wahren
rust-könner
moment, so funktioniert es überhaupt nicht, oder
aber mit clone funktioniert es
äh
das ist ja super wir
guck mal
die ide bietet mir an das umzuwandeln
aber das umgewandelte ist gar nicht
äquivalent zu dem hier
seht ihr das, so geht das nicht
aber, aber so geht es
ich versteh aber gar nicht warum nicht
weil unter der haube macht clone doch wahrscheinlich
auch, wow, what
also ok, leute
eins kann man den rust-leuten
nicht vorwerfen, sie hätten zu wenig
docs, ich mein
seriously, die funktion besteht aus
aus 3 zeilen rust
3 zeilen rust und 80 zeilen
docs
also das gegenteil von meinem
graben, ne heute, heute
muss rust, heute, musste
durch mit rust, so
ok, das haben wir auch
also den, den go part
haben wir auch umgewandelt, jetzt geht
es darum
die offer für den browser
zu createn, das können wir uns hier schon mal
merken
ok, create offer
bei go ist es 0
hier ist es none
neun, neun zeilen comments, ja
so, und jetzt brauchen
ok, das, jetzt, ok, das weiß ich nicht
wie es funktioniert, jetzt müssen wir ip-adressen
einsammeln, also endpoints
wohin das video geschickt werden soll
da muss ich
github web rtc
da muss ich bei denen gucken wie das
funzt in den examples
examples
wir hatten doch hier so einen single
port hier
ice restart
gather
gather complete
create a channel that is
blocked until ice gathering
is complete
wir blocken until ice gathering is complete
leute, ihr wollt auch schon immer
bis das ice gesammelt ist, blocken
gibts, gibts zu
nicer, nicer blocker
so, let
mut
per connection
completed, promise, await
lass mich raten, unwrap, ach ne, hier kein
unwrap, achso, ja moment
weil ich da später drauf warten will
alter, meine güte
und jetzt, ok
per connection, set
set local description
ich bau ein
programm mit
.net, backend
und low level rust
web rtc zeug
und ich hab nicht so super viel Ahnung
von rust, ok
per connection, set local, da
müssen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich diese offer da rein
schieben, dass das funktioniert
natürlich nicht, das wär viel zu einfach
wenn das einfach funktionieren würde, achso
reicht
await, unwrap
unwrap
das ist so hässlich, man
so, und jetzt muss ich warten, bis er alle IP-Adressen
discovered hat, wie funktioniert das so
gather, completed, receive
async, unwrap
nochmal unwrap, alles unwrappen
guck mal, die unwrappen das hier
auch nicht, warum nicht
achso, weil sie es einfach
weil sie es einfach droppen
auch gut
wir machen das exakt so
wie das Beispiel das sagt
also, da hätten wir doch das hier auch schon geschafft
ja, unic
achso, ja, track id
track id hab ich
nee, nicht track id, per connection id
hab ich nicht, brauch ich
auch nicht, werd ich einfach
ignorieren
so
also, heißt im Endeffekt, wir brauchen
jetzt
ah, wir brauchen noch, ok, wir brauchen das gleiche nochmal
für connections
tracks, once log, lw log
page map, arc
per connection
connections
ah, ok, nice, ritter ross, dankeschön für den sub
du bist mir auch heute auf github
gefollowed, hab ich gesehen
man hat mich heute mal wieder auf github eingeloggt, auf der Startseite
da hab ich deinen Namen gesehen
fällt mir grad ein, wo ich dich hier im Chat seh
so, connections, das passt
ok
also, jetzt
müssen wir die connections speichern
hier in dem Array, beziehungsweise in der Liste
du kannst mit Rust auf WebAssembly
aber keine UDP-Pakete versenden
nee, aber das ist ja auch nicht
auf WebAssembly-Basis, das ist ein
Server-Backend
letztendlich ruft der Server
per RTSP von Webcams
die Streams ab und schickt die an
beliebig viele Browser, die sich verbinden
ok, wie geht das jetzt nochmal hier?
connections, get
unwrap
write
calculate
machen wir das richtig so
ok
wie die Rust-Pros
Zeilen und Brüche rein
ok, so
connections, insert
eine ID
ok, ich brauch ne random
ok, komm, 1
ist doch vollkommen egal
und jetzt
die Per-Connection inserten
please, einfach funkt...
ah man, was ist denn das Problem
jetzt schon wieder? Achso, ARC
ok, ARC, new
muss das überhaupt in den ARC rein jetzt?
warum haben wir das nochmal in den ARC
gemacht?
ok, keine Ahnung, ich lass das einfach mal
als ARC, ok
connections geht nicht, weil
es mutable
ahja
das musst du hier oben bei Tracks auch machen
Ritter Rust heute
ja
vorgenommen, build
ey Leute, es bildet
das ist schonmal top
ok, hier müssen wir jetzt
jetzt wird es tatsächlich noch ein bisschen komplizierter
hier müssen wir jetzt
ein struct
returnen
und zwar soll das
struct folgendermaßen aussehen
offer und dann
client ID, ja gut, das ist relativ
easy
also brauchen wir noch ein struct
struct
nennen wir das einfach
ähm
ja, Connection Result
wie in C Sharp auch, struct
Connection Result
und da drin, ok, Pub
wir machen das Pub
so und da drin brauchen wir
jetzt was? Wir brauchen
Client ID
das ist
ein
32 oder so
und wir brauchen
Offer
das ist ein
Moment
wie
mach ich denn da jetzt ein C String
Const
nee, das ist Go, ne
Const, oje
Byte oder so
es gibt C String, das ist aber glaube ich
nur zum Zurückwandern, hier brauche ich
das ist ein Const
ok, Moment
Rust, Struct, Interop, C
Return
Offer
FFI, Char
ja, ähm
Struct
wie geht das jetzt
hatten wir das nicht letztens im Stream schonmal
ausprobiert
und ich hab's irgendwie wieder
gelöscht, Char
ja, C Char gibt's
was will er hier
nee, das ist, das ist die
das ist die Go Variante
so, Connection
Result
muss man das nicht noch irgendwie
Represent C
Represent C oder so was
irgendwie so
ja
ok, ich hoffe, ich hoffe das findst du
ich hoffe das findst du
Connection Result, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt
ein Struct, was wir hier returnen
und zwar mit
jetzt werden wir es auch erstmal in C Sharp
testen, ob's prinzipiell funktioniert
was ich da gebaut hab
ok, also Return
Connection Result
Client ID
machen wir mal hier ne Variable, da können wir die später
oder ja
ID 1
da können wir die später austauschen
ja, ID
und
Offer
ja, das muss jetzt in C String werden
jetzt wird's spannend
jetzt, jetzt, was hat der hier für Schmerzen
introduced
was will er von mir
achso, der will mir sagen
dass meine Funktion nix returned, gell
ja
ich verwende ID zweimal
wo, wo denn?
nicht, oder?
ich verwende ID nicht zweimal
wie jetzt?
ID ist ein Int, das sollte er doch kopieren, oder?
das sollte er doch checken
das will er nicht, weil, ah
weil's ein U32 ist
und das hier, ok
das ist ein I32, dann ist es ok
so, jetzt ist die große
Preisfrage, wie krieg ich
hier raus
einen
Konst
ähm, also wie krieg ich
jetzt, Moment
Pair Connection
wie hab ich das jetzt
in Go gemacht, hier
PC, Local Description, ok
das brauch ich hier auch
Local Description
äh
Unwrap aus irgendwelchen Gründen
wieder, wait, Unwrap, ok
und jetzt SCP
so, das ist die große Frage
wie krieg ich das jetzt in den C String
ja, ich
ja, ich bilde mir auch ein, dass ich das
vorgestern schon mal hatte, aber irgendwie hab ich's hier nicht mehr drin
hatte ich das vielleicht, Moment, Moment
hatte ich das vielleicht
hatte ich das im Benchmark Champ drinnen
ah ja, ja, genau
da hab ich's doch
da hab ich's doch, das hab ich die ganze Zeit gesucht
man, Str, ok
C, Str
New, Unwrap
und hier oben, Sternchen, Mut
wobei, es ist eigentlich
egal, so
oh, Rust, please
also was, C, Str, New
also Per Connection Logs, wait
also im Prinzip will ich das da haben
Import, genau, genau
sehr gut, sehr gut
Str, äh, ja, scheiß drauf
oh, meine Güte
so, und jetzt, so
natürlich nicht, warum
I found, but found
U, warum ist denn das ein U64
U64
warum ist meine ID auf einmal ein U64
ist das der Default-Typ dafür, oder wie
ey, dann meinetwegen
ein U64, soll mir recht sein
und das will er nicht, weil
Const, but found, C, Str
und das war das Into
Into, Raw
S, Pointer
ok, was hat er wieder für Schmerzen
Value borrowed here
after move
ok, ergibt Sinn, dafür ist Rust gut
ich hab's zuerst in die Collection eingefügt
anstatt da, ok, nice, Build
ok, jetzt
bin ich gespannt, ob das Chat gibt
was meint ihr
funzt das jetzt, oder
Pepega Crash
stimmt, dass man das Ding
Str nennen darf, komisch, ne
ich glaube auch
ich glaube, dass es funktioniert, weil in der Regel
wenn Rust kompiliert, dann crashed es selten
dann geht's einfach
ob's dann das macht, was man will
sei mal dahingestellt
so, jetzt müssen wir das hier noch ein bisschen anpassen
wir haben eine Rust-Methode, die
sich Init nennt, das ist korrekt
sich Create Connection nennt
das brauchen wir noch, und das ist übrigens
auch nicht LibRTC, sondern
WebRTC Linux
heißt das hier
so, Init haben wir, dann brauchen wir
Create Connection
schauen wir uns das mal von Go
Create Connection liefert zurück
ein Struct
das besteht
aus einem U64
und einem CharArray
also
ConnectionResult haben wir doch
hier schon drin, ConnectionResult
IDisposable
okay, das scheiß auf MemoryLeaks
bevor's kaputt geht, ich schmeiß das mal raus
ein InPointer
Uint64
gefolgt
von einem Pointer
zu einem String, ja, das sieht
gut aus
nenn ich SessionConnectionResult
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das funzt
ich werde das mal
äh, warum ist es
jetzt auf einmal kaputt?
ah, weil ich IDisposable
weggelöscht
hab, ja, komm
dann
dann sind wir halt MemorySafe
halbwegs, wenn's sein muss, wir tun einfach
so, wir gebaten einfach
wir machen einfach in das dispose nix
dann ist er zufrieden
so, letztendlich
wir returnen jetzt mal eh an der Stelle und sagen
jetzt InterOp
RustInit
InterOp
RustCreateConnection
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert
ClientID sollte 1 sein
und Offer sollte
irgendwie, ja, langer Text bei rauskommen
Präge, Leute
ich brauch mindestens 5
Präges, bevor ich das ausführen kann
damit das funktioniert
eine Runde Präge, please
ich trink mal was
in der Zwischenzeit
ok, 5 Präges sind zusammen
wir haben's geschafft, also
.NET
Run
was? Entry Point not found?
ich hab Rust gar nicht
compiled und rüberkopiert
null
Release?
ähm
CargoBuild
minus minus Release
ok, das zählt jetzt nicht
ich hab vergessen
Rust zu kompilieren, das macht
ja keinen Sinn
immer mit Cargo
CargoOutputPath kann man einstellen, wohin
der outputet
so wie mit minus O zum Beispiel
ne, das ist mir zu
zu doof
ich kopier's
ihr Schmollstring ist auch wieder am Start
ich kopier das von Hand
soll mir auch recht sein
auf jetzt
alter, der benutzt einfach, guck mal
das sind meine CPU-Cores hier oben
der kompiliert blazingly fast
highly efficient
so, MVTarget
Release, Web, ne
Linux
warum heißt das so dumm?
achso, weil ich das einfach so eingestellt
hab
da fällt mir nämlich ein
das ja
das GoBinary
und
das RustBinary nicht
gleich heißen können
dann heißt
das hier so, ja
WebRTC Rust
da kann man's wenigstens unterscheiden
so, WebRTC Rust
Punkt SO, hoch
nach Backend
alles klar
Lib WebRTC Rust und kopieren
in den Output, alles klar
auf geht's, bam, also
Chat, ich würde sagen
der erste Part hat
funktioniert mit dem Struct
die zweite Sache mit dem String
nicht so richtig
warum nicht?
Pointer
to
UTF-8
das sieht, also der C-Sharp
Teil sieht, finde ich, richtig
aus
was mach ich denn in den Go falsch?
alter
null, was mach ich
in Go falsch?
das hatten wir vorgestern auch
ja
möglich
ich weiß woran das liegt
Chat, ich weiß woran das liegt
guckt mal
ich glaube zumindest
dass ich weiß woran das liegt
da sind keine Encoding Errors
das ist weil das Memory freigegeben ist
ne, ich weiß woran
das liegt, guckt mal hier
das da
wird
wahrscheinlich freed
wenn die
Funktion returnt
der will ja
wobei, kopiert er das vielleicht?
kopiert er das vielleicht?
kann man das
klonen? okay, klonen
oh mein Gott, alter
das ist schon wirklich extrem hässlich
oder hier
Await Unwrap
what?
Unwrap
und dann machen wir gleich
hier S-Pointer drunter
oh
Unsafe, ja und?
alter, ich weiß, dass das Unsafe ist
man, dann lass ich's halt
weg und mach's hier unten
ja, ist ja, okay, so
Compile Action
Run
Fuck
ähm
war ich denn verkehrt?
okay, lass uns mal checken
ob das, ob das überhaupt
in Rust richtig ist
okay
wir müssen, wir müssen, wir müssen mal was gucken
das hier ist Client ID
Client ID ist ein U64
äh
und das hier ist auch
ein U64, das kann's schon mal
nett sein
Into Raw ist richtig
okay, ja
ja, ihr habt recht
ihr habt recht
das stand sogar in der Hilfe drin, gell
Into Raw
und dann
Moment, will der das jetzt?
Moment, warum geht denn das?
Warum geht denn das? Das ist doch hier oben
Kunst und nicht Mut
Rust is ugly
Ja, Rust is ugly, das seh ich auch so
So, funzt es jetzt
ausprobieren
auf kompilieren
mach hier ne
ist nicht Blazingly Fast Compiler gerade?
Ah
viel besser
viel besser schon
da fehlt aber doch was, oder?
das ist ein bisschen wenig
aber
wir geben das hier trotzdem noch mal aus, kurz
fmt
äh nicht
äh warte mal, print
wir sind ja nicht in Go
pair connection
local description
oh man
was, äh wait
unwrap
ja, okay
toll, toll, ganz toll, Rust, perfekt
äh format string, sehr gut
wir lassen es auch noch mal
hier ausgeben
aber ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen kurz
das ist ein bisschen wenig
und ich glaube auch nicht, dass
der eigentlich hiermit aufhören soll
ehrlich gesagt
doch
das ist zu wenig
das ist nicht
genug, da fehlen
die ganzen Tracks und sowas drinnen
aber ich hab die Tracks hinzugefügt
ähm
warum
offert der kein Track?
das versteh ich jetzt
null
haben wir hier irgendwas falsch, Media Engine
payload type 690
okay das können wir noch
können wir noch im Spinner schreiben
wie weit wir sind
äh schwer zu sagen
also
das ist auf jeden Fall verkehrt
das ist, das ist zu wenig, was der hier
zurück, zurück liefert
mit Media Engine
Media Engine, haben wir hier alles
Settings Engine
UDP, das ist zu wenig, das ist zu kurz
was da zurückkommt
also in, ihr habt's ja gesehen
in, in Go kommt da viel mehr
zurück
da fehlen, da fehlen beispielsweise auch die ganzen
Tracks
mir ist fast so, als ist
Tracks leer, könnte das sein
spindle
kegway, wir können es leider nicht
anders debunken gerade
mir ist fast so, als
wäre Tracks leer
die Oneslogs mach ich nicht leer
außerdem kann man Oneslogs gar nicht
leer machen
dann müsst ihr meckern
siehste, Tracks ist leer
das wird gar nicht ausgeführt
ich glaub, hab ich Add Track vergessen
oh, ich hab, Leute
Add
Track hab ich vergessen, lul
ja kein Wunder
dass das nicht funktioniert
Add Track
heißt das so, Add Track
Create Track
okay, ja
ja dann ist klar, dass es nicht drinnen
auftaucht, wenn man es gar nicht aufruft
Interop Rust
Create Track, so, jetzt noch mal
please, und jetzt einfach funktionieren
ja, das sieht schon deutlich
besser aus, kegway
das sieht viel
besser aus, so muss das sein, sehr schön
das ist gut so
das ist gut
so, so sieht das in Go, so
so ungefähr sieht das in Go auch aus
du kannst noch was
das DBG
Macro benutzen
was macht das?
das macht
Zeug
ach, das gibt die Zeile aus
gut zu wissen, das ist nice, das brauch ich
okay
also, dass der Part funzt
dann gehts weiter
so viel ist es gar nicht mehr, was wir umziehen müssen
und dann kommt der Moment der Wahrheit, ob es funktioniert
aber das sieht gut aus
es sieht wirklich, es sieht wirklich gut aus
also jetzt nicht, nicht Rust
Code an sich, sondern das sieht
funktionierend aus, gerade
so, also
weiter, das funzt
wir kriegen jetzt die, komm
lass uns der Ordnung halbern, hier hab ich schon
mutt hingeschrieben, so, also das
haben wir, wir haben ja fast alles
guck, das haben wir umgezogen
das haben wir umgezogen
uns fehlt eigentlich nur noch
das hier, und das ist echt
überschaubar, nur noch
das hier fehlt uns
so, also das heißt
wir brauchen jetzt eine Function
gleiche hier nochmal
die heißt jetzt allerdings
setAnswer
da kriegen wir als Parameter jetzt
allerdings einen
das ist natürlich
die Frage, ob das denn
eigentlich kann das
auch ein Const
String sein
Const C Char
ja, komm, das heißt einfach
beste Benamen überhaupt
Types mismatch, hier
muss nichts returned werden
ok, jetzt wir brauchen das gleiche
wieder wie hier
wir brauchen
die Connections
also die
die per Handshake schon aufgebaut wurden
wo ist das hier, Connections
ah, Moment, Moment
Moment, Moment, eins hab ich ja noch vergessen
wir brauchen
die Connections, wir brauchen noch einen
Parameter, und zwar wir brauchen noch
ein U64
und zwar die ID
von dem Ding
brauchen wir noch
das muss hier auch noch übergeben werden
sonst funktioniert das nicht
ich hoffe
ich mach das hier schon
ok, also
Set
Connection Result, kompletter Schwachsinn
Max, keine Ahnung was du da gebaut hast
so
und das ist jetzt genau das gleiche
genau das gleiche wie bei
Go
Uint
und das ganze soll als
UTF-8 C String Pointer da
reingeschoben werden, GachiBass
also wir bekommen
eine ID, wir bekommen hier
das Array mit den Connections
in das ich jetzt übrigens
nur lesen möchte
das ist so hässlich, oder?
so, jetzt kommt's drauf an
also, Get
die ID
und dann
krieg ich die Connection raus
Unwrap
was sonst?
was hat der hier für Schmerzen?
wir brauchen ein
und, wir brauchen eine
eine Referenz auf ID
diese Schaben
die Tonnamen sind aber nicht
das ist
korrekte
korrekte .net
Naming Convention
die Rust Sachen nicht
die Rust Sachen sind so gemacht wie das
die Rust Leute gerne hätten
ok, Pair Connection
da müssen wir jetzt
Set
Remote Description
brauchen wir da jetzt
und irgendwie müssen wir jetzt den String Pointer
wieder zurück umwandeln
in einen
oh
wie geht denn das?
wie wandel ich? das muss ich googeln
das muss ich googeln
ähm
C Char Pointer
Rust to String
How to Convert
uns? nein
ich will
ja, das will ich
sowas in der Richtung
C String from
ok, das ist einfacher als gedacht
ehrlich gesagt
C String from Pointer
let's
was hat er jetzt?
was hat er für Schmerzen?
in .net sind doch mit Tonnamen
immer groß
ja, ähm
du hast recht
no
I never tried to compile
Web Assembly and I never used
STL in Rust
du hast recht
die Methodennamen sind falsch
komm, wir machen es korrekt
dass sich Microsoft freut
können die mir gleich ein paar
Influencer Millionen
überweisen
so, gut
ok, ähm, was kommt jetzt als nächstes?
also das funst nicht, warum funsten
das nicht? weil
unsafe, ok unsafe
alter
was ist mit der IDE los? die ist ja voll im Arsch
ja, add unsafe
to function, bam, geht nicht
wahrscheinlich weil an der falschen Stelle, muss bestimmt
hier hin, ne, muss
dahin
ja, nice, gut
try and error, wo muss unsafe hin?
also an der Rust IDE
müssen die echt noch ein bisschen arbeiten
und jetzt
müssen wir hier die Remote Description
setzen, wie macht man das
jetzt? RTC
wie ist das?
RTC
Session Description
gibt es da irgendwie so ein pass
oder sowas?
was soll ich umbenennen?
ach unsafe drum herum
ach quatsch, das ist alles was ich hier mache
ist unsafe, ok pass gibt es
nicht, from?
from klingt gut, aber das ist from
jetzt ist die Frage, wie
passe ich denn jetzt meinen String
als RTC Session Description
marschall
unmarsch, ne
ja, das ist jetzt wieder sehr
fmt, ne
into, what?
das ist jetzt wieder sehr fivehead
ich kapier wieder die einfachsten Sachen nicht
vielleicht so?
answer?
achso, guck mal da, SCP String
still
let's
unwrap
was sonst, selbstfall
wie immer unwrap
ok, und hier
awaiten und unwrappen
ich träume
heut Nacht von unwraps
das geht nicht, weil
ah, weil es ein C String ist
jetzt ist die Frage, wie ich ein
C String, kann ich to String sagen?
sehr schön
ex
Moment, da gibt es einfach, wait a minute
das geht doch im Leben
ich kann doch garantiert nicht sagen
into, ne Moment
to String
ne, ne, es ist
jetzt habe ich mir schon was gedacht, wenn das
was, ok, obviously
alles klar, Rustfehlermeldung
conste8 doesn't implement standard
format display, conste8
cannot be formatted
beste, alles klar
into
to owned
so, also das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert
aber kann ich vielleicht
den hier to String machen
into C String
to String
ich bin immer noch
etwas verwirrt
etwas verwirrt, wie ich das da hinbekomme
C String from pointer
to String und was
to owned
unwrap
alter
was ist, Moment
was ist das wieder
das ist ja ausgeburter
Hölle, das könnte ja direkt aus irgendeiner
C++ Anleitung entspringen
from pointer to String
to owned unwrap
ähm, so jetzt haben wir ein
und das geht immer noch nicht
und da muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nochmal hinten dran
machen
nochmal to String, hä
oder to owned
ne, to String
monkaS
monkaS, Mann
was, to owned, kann man auch machen
ok
ja, hier habe ich
to String ja schon drin
warum gibt es to String und owned
ne, das ist wieder etwas anderes
der will hier einen String, das funktioniert
hä?
Moment
to owned sagt doch
ganz klar
ach ne, es returnt einen String, ok
warum gibt es
hier sagt to owned
ganz klar
es returnt einen Slice und keinen String
und wenn man es dann einfügt
dann returnt es
doch einen String
hä?
ok, man muss das nicht verstehen
ob da was funktioniert
meinst du
es liegt an der Idee
ok, Prägetime, ob es funktioniert
ich glaube wir haben alles umgezogen
answer haben wir gemacht
set answer
set remote description haben wir gemacht
ok Leute, der Moment der Wahrheit
wir haben
wir haben das portiert
von Go nach Rust
jetzt
kommt es drauf an, ob das funktioniert
also
interop rust create track
offer
interop rust
create connection
ich meine wir haben nichts
an den Interfaces geändert
die haben alle die gleichen Datentypen
und so, das müsste jetzt 1 zu 1 austauschbar
sein, Präge
richtig hart reinprägen, Chat
es muss jetzt
massive geprägt werden, dass das funktioniert
so und jetzt haben wir set
interop
rust
set answer
äh
achso, weil es ein int64 ist
int64
so
jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert
es crasht schon mal nett beim Start
so
checking
oh, oh shit
es ist gecrasht
es ist gecrasht, ich weiß nicht genau
wo es gecrasht ist
ich mein, es ist ge
crasht bei
okay
zeile 59, okay
äh neun neun
nee, wat
zeile 69, seh ich das richtig
sind wir gecrasht
hier sind wir gecrasht
okay
warum
warum sind wir hier gecrasht
das sieht alles gut aus
ich glaube
wir
er crasht, weil
stand da auch irgendwas
ah, result
unwrap
mpsc send
channel closed
was soll das jetzt bedeuten
ja, fehlerbehandlung
ist überbewertet
was ist mpsc send
channel closed
was möchte mir es sagen
wir suchen, wir gucken uns noch mal
ein Beispiel an
set remote description, offer, await
äh, ja so ähnlich
ja so
ähnlich, können wir das
moment, wie heißt das Ding, ich brauch mal ein ordentliches
Beispiel
set remote description
äh, Code kann man wieder nicht durchsuchen, weil ich ja eingeloggt
bin
dann gibt es eigentlich
nur eine Möglichkeit, wir
klonen uns da schnell
und greppen da drinnen mal
wow
alter
ganz ruhig terminal, ganz ruhig
ganz ruhig
äh, examples
examples
grepp
nach set remote description
ups
ja
ice, ice restart
haben wir auch irgendwas, wo
wo ich
die erst, wo ich die
Anfrage schick
und nicht umgedreht
hier
set remote description, answer
ja, data
channels create
der Rest ist eigentlich
offer
answer
okay, wir können uns nur das data
channels create rust Beispiel angucken
soll wir auch
recht sein, remote
okay, remote
await? macht
der Typ, ist das was, was
rust direkt wegräumt, möglich
ich hab keine Ahnung, was mir rust sagen
möchte, ja
ja, connection set remote
also
irgendwas ist closed
also ich meine, es ist gut, dass an der
Stelle ein unwrap steht, weil
da sehen wir wenigstens, woran es liegt
also wenn ich das richtig verstehe
der macht das hier auch so
await? ist glaube ich das gleiche wie
unwrap, oder?
wenn man den passenden
result type hat, oben
das geht nur, wenn man den passenden
result type hat hier, was ich nicht habe
weil es eine Funktion ist
für c
aber, heißt im Endeffekt
so, was räumt
er hier auf?
channel closed
wir gucken einfach mal in die issues rein
äh, ja
super, geil
ja, so, toll
geil, okay, wir
pinten nix dazu
es ist closed, ja
ja, die Frage ist, warum das
closed ist, ich mein
das
hier funzt ja offensichtlich
das ist die Antwort
so, okay, chat
gear
ich mach mal hier das Zeug weg
meine Ausgaben, wir geben mal in rust
das aus, was da reinkommt
vielleicht ist ja
wie war das? dbg
dbg
string
gucke, ob das funktioniert
was?
what? reftemp?
ich hab nirgends wo was von reftemp stehen
achso, weil das moved ist
wait a minute
hä? nee, da ist nix moved
muss ich jetzt so machen?
okay, da bin ich zu pp dafür
keine Ahnung, wie das funzt
äh, print
achso, format
achso, man
achso, man kann das
ah
man macht das hier rein, okay, das ergibt
Sinn, ja, verstehe
wieso sind die Augen kaputt?
wegen rust oder wegen dem
Kontrast vom Editor?
chat gear, ich muss mal chat gucken
ich hab bestimmt wieder was
ja, aber was soll mir das sagen? also was muss ich anders machen?
das kann schon sein, dass rust
das aufräumt
okay, start
zack, okay, es ist wieder gecrashed
das war ja klar
also, ergibt jetzt aus
natürlich nice formatiert, ja, dass man alles
erkennt, okay, das funktioniert
da kommt auf jeden Fall schon mal das Richtige rein
mpsc
send channel closed
ich hab absolut
keine Ahnung
was das Ding von mir will
null
was macht denn das remote description?
guck mal mal rein
wirklich keinen Plan
was das macht
wie heißt das? mpsc
mpsc
gathering
complete
äh, hattest du nicht
irgendwo
code shows
watch is non-blocking from the
alter, boah ey
was ist das für ein Syntax, man
the fuck
ich mach doch gar nichts direkt mit diesem channel
das verstehe ich nicht
was die mir damit sagen wollen
also was ich auch nicht checke ist
was der
wo hier irgendwas
ich blocke?
ich
ich erwaite und unwrappe
öfters mal
aber das kann ja
nicht verboten sein, ne
ich hab keine Ahnung was die hier sagen
was relevant ist
ey, keine Ahnung
was könnte das denn sein, man
was hat der hier für Schmerzen
sollen wir einfach mal
das ignorieren
nee, das wird nicht funktionieren
das hat schon seinen Sinn
räumt der vielleicht wirklich irgendwo
ich mein wo
create ich denn die connection
ich mein eigentlich
äh achso
das receive, ja das ist
bei, hier ist das
gathering complete ist
das, ja
das erwaite ich
bis das fertig ist, aber
das machen die auch, das machen die auch hier
guck das machen die hier auch vorher
und das muss ich auch machen
sonst kann ich an den
Ja, keine, also ich hab, ich hab legit, ich mein, wir haben, das Gute ist, wir haben den Code 1 zu 1 von Go rüber übersetzt und das funktioniert.
Das heißt also an der, an der prinzipiellen Logik kann das nicht liegen.
Eine Sache, die ich halt nicht checke ist, wo macht der überhaupt was mit ihr?
Yourself is closed.
Return error?
Okay, kann man irgendwie sagen?
Await?
Oh jetzt, wie geht das mit Pattern Matching?
Kann man sich nicht irgendwie den, den Error irgendwie, ja genau, Result?
Ne.
Ich dachte, es gibt irgendwie einen speziellen Error-Typ oder so.
Ey, wir machen Unwrapped, ist schon okay.
Okay, was macht der hier?
Log Await?
Sieht die irgendwas nach einem Channel aus?
Und ja, ja, ich bekomm, ich bekomm ne Antwort.
Wisst ihr was, wir kompilieren das Ganze nochmal kurz im, im Debug.
Bekommt man im Debug-Mode jetzt, bekommt man da mehr Infos?
Irgendwas, irgendwas Sinnvolles?
Wenn ich die Library im Debug-Modus kompiliere?
Run Rust Backtrace 1 to Display, okay.
Hoffentlich geht das auch so.
Hey!
Komm mal.
Sieht man sogar was.
Nice.
So, also, wo kackt der jetzt ab?
Unwrap?
Ja, 59, 58.
Das, das, das, also wo das ist, hab ich schon gecheckt.
Hier, 58, hier bei dem Unwrap, ja, das ist mir auch klar, dass es das ist.
So, und jetzt sagt er was?
Core Result, Unwrap, Set, Answer.
Ja, okay.
Was?
Cached Park?
What?
Blocking Region Guard?
Aber das wird hier nirgendswo aufgeworfen.
Ich hab's dann zumindest noch nicht gefunden.
Okay, die Fehlermeldung ist komplett useless.
Für mich jetzt zumindest.
Unset Rust Backtrace Run.
Hier kann man das, kann man das Ganze also wieder, wieder kompilieren, komplett.
Lass uns mal weitergucken, was er hier macht.
So, Desk, Past, Past.
So, wo könnte der hier?
Hier, Get Transceivers vielleicht.
Hier irgendwo?
Get Transceivers, Self Remote Description.
Du bekommst von der Library einen Channel Receiver.
Ach so.
Du meinst, das ist gar keine Fehlermeldung in dem Sinn?
Sondern es gibt eine Fehlermeldung, weil der hier aus dem Scope rausgeht.
Aber warum, aber warum, Moment.
Aber warum, ähm, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Aber warum kackt der dann ab beim Unwrap und nicht irgendwie erst danach?
Oder, aber wo bekomm ich irgendwas?
Ich seh hier nix.
Meinst du das Ding?
Für die, nee, Gather Complete, das ist doch was ganz, was, was anderes.
Das ist doch hier fertig.
Nee, das, das kann, das hat doch damit nix zu tun.
Also, das wär doch, wär ultra weird, hätte das was damit zu tun.
Also, das ist ja für, für, für IP-Adressen, Lookup und, und, äh, Endpunkte sammeln.
Was hat das jetzt, was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Du meinst, das hier müsste ich quasi speichern, sozusagen?
Den, den Option?
Oder was kommt denn da überhaupt raus?
Meinst du, ich muss, meinst du, ich muss das hier irgendwo speichern?
Das hier?
Nee, nee, das, das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ich mein, wisst ihr, was wir machen können?
Kack Wait?
Ähm, also, wir lassen das einfach mal weg, wir lassen das mal weg.
Und, kann man, kann man in Rust irgendwie Async Sleep?
Also, quasi sowas wie Task Delay?
Tokyo Time, was?
Time?
Sleep?
Duration, okay, das ist gut.
Äh, Duration?
Oh Gott, wie funzt denn das jetzt?
Äh, gibt's da nicht irgendwie einen gescheiten...
From Seconds, okay.
Wir lassen ihn einfach mal 5 Sekunden schlafen.
Und jetzt, Await?
Unwrap?
Nee, einfach so?
Wartet das jetzt an der Stelle 5 Sekunden?
Nee, im Camp Champ ist das nicht drinnen, das hab ich noch nicht gepusht.
Außerdem geht's ja um den Library Code.
Wartet das jetzt hier 5 Sekunden?
Schauen wir mal.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Okay, äh, nee.
Send.
Also, auch wenn ich das hier nicht verwende, juckt ihn das nicht.
Das ist es schon mal nett.
Okay, was?
Die machen hier auch nichts Spezielles, ne?
Aber was ist denn das hier, Done?
Nee, das ist...
Das hat nichts damit zu tun.
Das hier ist ihr komisches Signaling.
Das hat mit dem Kram nichts zu tun.
Okay, das ist für die Shell.
Danach wird geclosed.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was das Problem ist.
Also, jede FFI-Funktion bekommt ihre eigene Runtime.
Ja, ist das schlimm?
Ich mein...
Ich hab hier so ein paar globale Dinger.
Ich würd den Tokio-Campel ehrlich gesagt auch weglassen.
Aber dann funzt die Hälfte nicht, weil die intern Tokio-Zeug verwenden.
Wenn die Library ein Background-Task spawnt, dann ist das weg.
Du kannst auch eine Static Runtime machen.
Aha.
Ich mach das nur, damit es funktioniert, ja?
Also...
Ich will das gar nicht verwenden.
Ich muss das aber verwenden, weil die Library das benutzt.
Ey, ich hab echt keinen Plan.
Wir haben 1 zu 1 von Go umgezogen.
Das muss jetzt irgendwelche Rust-Spezialitäten sein.
Was ist denn, wenn ich das einfach ignoriere, was der hier macht?
Dann wird's wahrscheinlich einfach nicht gehen, aber nicht abkacken.
Ja.
Jetzt kackt er nicht ab.
Aber es funktioniert halt nicht.
Alter, was ist das?
Okay, Remote Description.
Das Zeug kann halt keiner lesen.
Was? Media, Media, RTC.
Ist mir wurscht, ob du das empfehlen würdest oder nicht.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich Rust verwende, ist,
weil ich die Library verwenden will und gucken will,
ob man das noch ein bisschen schneller als mit Go hinkriegt.
So.
Was macht der hier unten für Dinger?
Hier, guck mal da.
Transceiver.
Schmollstring.
Der SCP scheint, der scheint konform zu sein, ja.
Aber das kann auch nicht das Problem sein.
Da wird's wahrscheinlich eine andere Meldung geben.
DTLS-Transport.
Es wäre halt einfach zu geil,
wenn ich irgendwie sehen würde,
an welcher Code-Stelle in der Library der verreckt, ja.
Weil ...
Ich seh ja nur meine Zeile 59.
Wen juckt's?
Ich muss wissen, wo der hier abkackt.
Ich hab keinen Plan, was die hier treiben, Alter.
Der Backtrace hat ...
Rust-interne Sachen gesagt.
Äh, Moment.
Der war nicht so wirklich aussagekräftig.
Guck hier.
Es gilt, dass er ...
Probleme hat.
Hier, in meiner Zeile 65.
Runtime-RS.
Von Tokio.
Plogged on.
Multithreaded.
Enter.
Runtime.
Cache. Park.
Unwrap.
Core result. Unwrap.
Okay, und dann ...
Bam.
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ich benutze das ...
Mit diesem Tokio Main ja nicht,
weil ich da so scharf drauf bin.
Sondern ...
Weil das das Einzige ist, wie es funktioniert hat.
Ich hab halt absolut keine Ahnung.
Also wenn ich das lösche,
hier zum Beispiel, dann ...
Äh, geht's immer noch?
Okay.
Nee, er kompiliert, aber er funktioniert nicht.
Er erzählt ja auch hier,
dass das jetzt nicht safe ist,
weil das Async ist.
Und ich kann's jetzt nicht ...
Und ich kann's jetzt nicht
Awaiten.
Gibt es so was wie ein Hardest Wait
ohne Await oder ...
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Gibt es nicht ein normales Wait?
Einfach ...
Äh.
Mehr Errorhandling.
Es gibt keine Errors, die ich handeln kann.
Ey, das geht nicht.
Ey, das ist halt doof.
Wie würde ich dem denn sagen,
dass der alles mit der gleichen
Runtime, was auch immer, das ...
Okay.
Tokio Rust Main.
Hier.
As it ...
If it was synchronously ...
Was?
Starting a new Runtime
each time it is ...
Ich mein, das stört mich nicht.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht so
schlau.
Excel ist Standard Library mittlerweile.
Use current thread Runtime.
Aha.
To use the single ...
To use the single thread Runtime,
known as the current thread Runtime,
the macro can be ...
Und dann werden die alle auf dem gleichen Thread ausgeführt, oder wie?
Okay.
Ich copy-paste
das jetzt einfach mal rein.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Das ...
Das wird's nicht bringen, ne?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist massive 5-Fet-Rust.
Unwrap.
Die Fehlermeldung im Chat ...
Hier.
Moment, ich hab die Hälfte ...
Alter.
Mein Copy-Paste ist wieder
on point.
Zweifel, dass man damit groß was anfangen kann.
Habe ich jetzt überall?
Single threaded ...
Excellent.
Schauen wir mal aus.
Äh.
Wird abgekackt.
Wir wissen ja noch nicht mal,
ob das an irgendwelchen Tokio-Sachen liegt.
Wettgeteim. Ne, heute ist es ein bisschen länger.
Equivalent code.
Not using Tokio main.
Tokio Runtime. Build a new multithread.
Enable all. Build unwrap.
Block on.
Alles klar.
Aber wenn ich das mach,
muss ich dann
den Code, den ich ausführen will,
in irgend so ein komisches Ding hier reinwrappen?
Das kann es doch nicht sein.
Alles ...
Also, oder ...
Oder
schreibe ich dann irgendwie da oben hin
Tokio ...
Ich bezweifle auch irgendwie, dass das das Problem ist.
Wartet mal.
Suchen wir jetzt mal hier drinnen.
Silver. Captain ...
Sergeant Silver, danke.
Du musst nur die Funktion per Runtime get
unwrap, block ...
Aber wenn ich das so hab ...
Guck mal.
Wenn ich das so hab, ist das dann nicht
auch alles in der gleichen Runtime,
weil hier irgendwie
was dransteht? Also da wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
wie ich das machen soll.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt, ich bräuchte
jede Funktion
doppelt.
Im Prinzip jede Funktion doppelt.
Das ist super weird, Champ.
Das heißt, ich brauche
jede Funktion hier doppelt
und würde dann aus der
C-Funktion
nur noch eine Rust-Funktion aufrufen
mit Runtime get unwrap
block on.
Macht dir das Bock? Na dann.
Das wirkt äußerst planlos gerade.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich das hinkriege,
heute das zu beseitigen.
Also ich meine, im Endeffekt bräuchte ich
dann quasi
sowas.
Machen wir das mal so.
In it.
Dann machen wir das hier weg.
Das kommt dahin.
Das kommt weg.
In it internal oder sowas.
Warum?
Pfundst das?
Und dann würde ich quasi sagen,
das muss ja
schon mal nicht extern C sein.
Und dann würde ich quasi
sinngemäß sagen,
so oder?
Okay.
Dann bin ich aber
gespannt jetzt.
Also ich baue mir eine Runtime.
In it sollte nicht mehr
Async sein.
Ach das hier.
So.
Heißt im Endeffekt,
hier in it, da kann ich das ja machen.
So. Heißt im Endeffekt,
Tokio Runtime Builder New, Multithreaded,
Block on.
Ne warte mal.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen einen
Runtime und das muss in so einen
Lock Once rein.
Boah ist das eklig man.
Ähm.
Runtime.
Was hat er jetzt?
Achso ja.
Das kann.
Ähm.
So.
So in it.
Runtime get
Unwrap.
Okay. Also.
Das heißt wir sagen jetzt.
Runtime set.
Runtime.
Okay.
Ich hätte ja nicht gedacht, dass das überhaupt
Unwrap.
Was das kompiliert.
Hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht.
So. Meinst du das so?
So und jetzt würde ich
im Endeffekt jedes Mal,
wenn ich das aufrufe.
So in etwa.
Wir gucken mal was passiert, wenn ich
das hier aufrufe, ob das nicht gleich crasht.
Ne es crasht nicht gleich.
Das wird noch nicht funktionieren, aber.
Gleiche Error.
Zumindest können wir jetzt ausschließen, dass das irgendein Tokyo
Shit ist.
Gut. Also das heißt wir haben hier.
Das ist ja gar kein so großer Akt.
Das zu fixen.
Also im Endeffekt.
Das kann ich mir Copy Pasten.
Das brauche ich jetzt 50 mal.
So das heißt.
Im Endeffekt nennen wir das hier mal.
Internal.
Oh.
Zack.
Das kommt hier rüber. Das kommt weg.
Das kommt
so hin. So und das muss nicht
mehr Ace. Doch das muss nicht mehr
Ace 5 sein. Und das muss nicht mehr
extern C sein.
Okay.
Und was habe ich jetzt vergessen?
Worum es geht.
Ähm.
Web RTC mit Rust.
Webcam streamen in Browser.
Runtime
an.
Unwrap.
Runtime
get unwrap.
Unwrap.
So.
Ach jetzt haben wir ja den Return
Code Krempel am Start.
Create. Moment.
Was hat er denn jetzt überhaupt für Probleme hier oben?
Was will er hier?
Ach Multiple Times.
Und jetzt? Will er was?
Achso. Ja wie kriege
ich da. Wie kriege ich denn
da jetzt Return Times zurück?
Oder macht er das automatisch?
Ne.
Achso.
Das checkt er automatisch. Okay ich muss
gar nichts machen. Nice.
Ja das ist.
Okay das ist wirklich nicht so kompliziert
das jetzt umzustellen.
Dann brauchen wir nur die zwei Funktionen.
Da haben wir schon.
So dann copy paste ich mir das hier gerade nochmal drüber.
So.
Das heißt jetzt set answer.
Moment das ist gut so.
Dann ruft es set answer internal auf.
Internal.
Das hat kein Return
Type.
Und das hier muss zwar noch
unsafe sein.
Aber kein extern C mehr.
Jetzt müsst ihr mal mit drauf gucken.
Das ich nicht irgendwas vergesse.
Was ist jetzt
für ein Problem? Achso das ist hier
noch dran.
Jetzt sollte der eigentlich.
Ich lecke critical information. Was ist jetzt?
Achso takes
to arguments. Okay.
MonkaS. Logisch.
Und async weg.
Takes to arguments heißt im Endeffekt
ähm
das da.
Und das takes id
und pointer
bis send dark zone.
Äh ja
unsafe
equate.
Warum darf unsafe nicht
überall hin?
Was ist jetzt?
Oje.
Jetzt ist dead.
Was?
Trade future is not implemented for.
No it's not english.
Was will der von mir überhaupt jetzt?
Ach async wieder rein.
Oh man.
Da muss man sich echt voll konzentrieren.
Kompiliert.
Ja.
Gut dann fehlt jetzt eigentlich nur noch eine Sache.
Dann okay.
Blenden wir das um. Internal. Das hier ist easy.
Da gibt's nix input.
Nix output.
Das kommt weg.
Extern C kommt weg.
Das kommt auch weg.
Das kann by the way auch weg.
Ja ja okay.
Create track
muss das heißen.
Hat kein input.
Internal.
Bekommt auch keine
id.
So hab ich irgendwas
gecheckt?
If you have any questions
you can ask them in the chat.
But my english
is not yellow from the egg.
Ich hab keine Ahnung
ob ich irgendwas
verkehrt gemacht hab.
Nutella
ohne Butter drunter.
Okay.
Wir gucken mal ob es funktioniert.
Ich glaube
Flixkrone hast du irgendwas gesehen?
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay.
Prager time.
Prager.
Lass das jetzt funktionieren.
Es geht.
Es funktioniert.
Nice.
Chat ich muss
ehrlich sagen
das ist eines der
wenigen Vorkommnisse.
Kommt ja sonst nie vor.
Ohne den Chat
hätte ich das
diesmal nicht hingekriegt.
Der Chat ist ja sonst oftmals
ziemlich community-ge.
Aber heute
war der Chat sehr hilfreich.
Der Flixkrone auch gerade.
Und nicht nur der Odolmed.
Aber ein paar
kennen sich eindeutig besser mit Rust aus
als ich und andere im Chat.
Okay. Zweimal
refreshen von der Seite funktioniert übrigens nicht.
Gescheit.
Weil ich
Massive PP-ger bin und die gleiche
Connection-ID wiederverwende.
Also das ist noch nicht
sonderlich schlau gebaut.
Aber es funktioniert.
Boah ist das... Alter.
Chat da wäre ich ohne euch nicht drauf
gekommen hier.
Beim besten Willen nicht.
Was war jetzt eigentlich nochmal
das Problem?
Moment. Ich hab's gefixt aber ich weiß
das Problem nicht mehr.
Wir wissen das nicht genau.
TokyoMain
Everytime
the function is called a new
Runtime.
At least the readme says so.
I have
no idea what this means.
Also
Ich gehe
davon aus, dass
das Problem ist aufgetreten,
weil die Funktionen
in unterschiedlichen Runtimes
gelaufen sind.
Async-Runtimes.
Man weiß es nicht.
Jetzt sorgen wir dafür, dass es immer
die gleiche Runtime ist, die das
ganze ausführt.
Was genau das Problem war, wissen wir aber trotzdem
nicht. Also warum er sich da dran
gestört hat. Wir wissen nur, dass er sich da dran gestört hat.
Also ich hab jetzt noch 20 Minuten Zeit.
Ich würde jetzt gerne das noch so bauen, dass
ich die Seite mehr als einmal
refreshen kann.
Das liegt daran.
Guckt hier.
I use the same Runtime.
But only because
FlixCoder is 5HeadChatter.
Ich
frag mich jetzt.
Rust ist zu optimiert.
Wir können das doch.
Ich brauch
Random-IDs.
Ich brauch Unique-IDs
für jeden Track
und für jede Connection.
Track ist nicht so wild.
Track gibt es eh nur
einen.
Gibt es sowas wie ein Atomic
ID-Connect?
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Gibt es
ein Atomic-Counter oder sowas?
Atomic...
Wow, what?
Da
hab ich auch schon dran gedacht.
UIDs.
Wobei, Leute, ich hab die
Idee.
Wir nehmen UIDs.
UIDs sind 128-Bit,
richtig?
Und 128-Bit
ist relativ
neu in .NET.
Gibt es ein U128?
Das machen wir. UID-Time,
Leute. Poggers.
UID-Stells.
UID-Rusts.
Das brauchen wir.
Welches...
Ist das das letzte
Sprite?
Documentation, Homepage.
1, 5.
Okay.
Wie geht das? Cargo...
Cargo-Ad, gell?
Cargo-Ad.
UUID.
Und jetzt Build.
Und jetzt erstmal wieder das halbe Internet
kompilieren.
Also, wo per
Connection?
Gehe ich übrigens richtig in der Annahme,
dass das jetzt auch deutlich schneller ist
beim Aufrufen der Funktionen,
weil er nicht für jeden Funktionsaufruf
einen extra...
eine extra Runtime starten muss.
"-f v4".
Was v4 ist?
V4 ist die Random-UID,
gell?
V4 ist random und die anderen sind irgendwie
mit Date-Time-Stamp oder sowas.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab.
Chat, ich hab mal eine Zusage für
ein duales Studio bekommen. Kann jetzt für die
Theoriephasen für speziell
entscheiden. Einmal IT-Security und einmal
KI. Sollte ich einen von beiden
nehmen, sind...
Was dir besser gefällt? Also, keine Ahnung,
was besser für dein Studium ist. Das kann ich nicht
beurteilen. Ich würde sagen, was dir gefällt.
Also Zukunft
haben mit Sicherheit beide
Sachen. IT-Security ist auf
jeden Fall, sagen wir mal, safer.
Da weiß ich, dass auf
jeden Fall Leute gebraucht werden.
KI ist so ein Zukunftsding, wo man sagen will, ja,
werden auch Leute gebraucht und wahrscheinlich in Zukunft
noch mehr. Also KI ist ein bisschen
vager, wo man jetzt nicht so 100%ig
weiß, wie viel werden es
mal wirklich, die da gesucht werden. Aber
IT-Security ist auf jeden Fall immer nicht verkehrt.
Wenn das nicht Hackermann ist, dann hätte ich
keinen Bock drauf. So, lass mal
hier kurz weitermachen. Also hier,
wie geht das jetzt? UUID
Import. Warum?
Warum?
Hier steht doch bestimmt V4.
Was ist denn hier?
V1, Timestamp und
Counter. Ist doch für mich vollkommen okay.
Timestamp und Counter.
Random Data.
Was ist denn der Default überhaupt?
Wir können
das mit Random Data machen.
Aber
wir testen ja erstmal prinzipiell, wie es funktioniert.
Okay, wie benutzt man den Kram denn
jetzt eigentlich?
New V4.
Moment, kann das sein,
dass nur V4 überhaupt
Moment, wir machen das
jetzt mal Main. Ich glaube, es ist sogar nur
V4 da.
ID2. Ich glaube, es gibt
gar nichts anderes als V4 bei mir.
Cargo Run.
Nee, Run?
Ach nee, das geht ja nicht, oder?
Hä?
Weil Library. Keckel.
Moment, ich bin
grad etwas verwirrt.
SU
128. Das ist top.
Das brauchen wir. Heißt im Endeffekt
auch, den anderen Krempel
müssen wir umstellen
auf U128.
Client ID.
Achso.
Moment, Moment, Moment,
Leute. Gibt es überhaupt in C
ein... Naja,
gucken wir einfach mal, was
er sagt.
Jaja, ich mach das dann.
What the fuck?
U64?
Achso, bei Connections.
Ja, Moment, bei Connections ist ja wurscht.
Bei Connections
kann das noch U64
bleiben. Moment, ich
blicke grad nicht mehr durch.
Ähm.
Ich...
Wo sind wir jetzt? Insert.
ID.
Hä?
Expected U64? Warum?
Ach, weil... Nee, hä?
Wieso?
Es sind doch beides 128.
Und U64?
Hä?
Was? Ach, jetzt ist es bei
Get.
Wo sind wir jetzt?
Connections.
Ach, hier. Ah!
Not FFESafe.
Ja.
Ich weiß. Ich weiß.
Es ist not
FFESafe.
Okay.